j'ai une image dans ma tête d'un endroit
je ne sais pas si c'est réel
[Musique]
mais il y a un sentiment et le sentiment est
réel
salut mon amour salut papa je voulais
te parler de mon diplôme
je vais être là  dans les gradins je vais
te voir dans ton laissez-moi laissez-moi que
diriez-vous de vous rappeler en
prenant le jour de congé ici le patron
veut vous voir
j'ai un double de whisky tu es vraiment
désolé je veux te montrer quelque chose de
vraiment  cool
vous voyez tous ces gens dehors ils ne sont
pas
réels c'est une simulation
vous êtes prêt
il y a mon gars bienvenue à la maison cet endroit
est
écrasant dr isabel clemens pionnier
des simulations de boîtes de cerveau mondes simulés laids
pour générer une appréciation pour le
monde réel
pourquoi je ne me souviens d'aucun  de cela,
ne vous inquiétez pas, la
plupart des gens disent que l'ignorance est s'il vous plaît,
mais je dis que vous devez faire l'expérience de la
bonne
[musique]
pour comprendre que
vous savez exactement l'inverse,
je suis content de vous avoir entendu dire un mot dans la
rue.  J'ai eu des problèmes avec
les recherches d'
Isabella  je suis un peu désorienté tu es mon gars
papa l'obtention du diplôme je n'ai pas oublié que ça
fait quelques jours fous
j'ai obtenu mon diplôme il y a deux semaines l'ignorer
elle n'est pas réelle
elle se sent réelle
j'ai peur que ta tête ne soit pas droite
c'est presque comme un tour joué
greg  c'est vraiment mauvais alors comment pouvons-nous y remédier
un de ces jours vous allez
devoir choisir
entre ces mondes
c'est incroyable comme les
humains peuvent facilement s'habituer à même quelque chose de
spectaculaire
vous